hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast tough targets simple
genotyping complete solutions for
mitochondrial disease CRISPR
pharmacogenetics and neuroscience
research presented by Deena Sullivan a
product manager at cannon biomedical I'm
Suzy Valdez of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's events we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by cannon biomedical for more
information about our sponsor visit
www.meliar.com/mpanel.htm a button
located at the lower left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appear on the screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation also notice you're viewing
the presentation in a slide window
just click on that screen icon located
at the lower right if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support button
at the top right of the presentation
window or use that Q&A button and let us
know you're having a problem good news
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left hand corner and follow the process
to obtain your credits please join me
now in welcoming Dana Sullivan a
presenter I will now turn the
presentation over to her welcome Dina
Thank You Susie and thank you for that
kind introduction thank you for joining
me today today I'm excited to present on
tough targets simple genotyping complete
solutions for mitochondrial disease
CRISPR pharmacogenetics and neuroscience
before I start I do have to share some
disclaimers so all of the products I'm
discussing today are for research use
only they're not for use in diagnostic
procedures you can find licensing
information and user guides on our
website
Kanon biomedical products are available
in the United States direct from Canon
by
medical and we have distributors
throughout Europe and in Canada and
lastly no-boil is a trademark of canon
biomechanical here is just a quick
agenda slide of the topics I'll be going
over today let's get started with Canon
and genetics as I am sure not all of you
know the Canon has entered into this
field for those of you who aren't aware
of Canon biomedical you may be wondering
why we are presenting here at lab roots
you may also be wondering if we are
related to the Canon who offers cameras
and printers well the short answer is
yes we are the same however we are a
smaller subsidiary of that larger parent
company the next question you may have
is what do you do do you offer
microscopes for make it or cameras for
my microscopes or some sort of medical
imaging well the answer here is no but
today I will discuss what we do offer as
I mentioned Canon biomedical is a newer
subsidiary of Canon the company was
launched in March of 2015
however biomedical products aren't
completely new to Canon in fact our
first president was a medical doctor who
developed imaging technologies to help
aid in the diagnosis of active
tuberculosis in the Japanese population
since then canon has always been
interested in serving the medical
healthcare and research community so in
2015 they launched a specific company
dedicated to the biomedical field Canon
biomedical goal is to focus on products
for life science researchers and
molecular diagnostics and in September
of that same year we launched our first
commercial life science products these
are researchers only noble genotyping
assays which I will discuss in more
detail today
for the rest of this presentation I
would like to focus on the different
applications of where the novel
genotyping reagents can help you in your
research I think it's easy to agree that
there are many things that you often
consider when you need to genotype a
sample and there are different
situations where genotyping may be
required on this section on the right
you will see three of these situations
where you often have a need to genotype
samples the first situation is a pre
screen so maybe you are selecting a
sample to include or exclude from a
larger study the second is a screen
which is a more retrospective approach a
good example of this might be screening
CRISPR clones for a specific mutation
and then lastly you could be genotyping
to verify something that you already
learned from a different method or was
unclear from a different method so for
example maybe you send out samples for
full genome sequencing and you need to
verify a rare or difficult to genotype
target that came back as indeterminate
depending on the type of variation or
variations you are investigating you
will need to choose a specific
technology and as we know there are many
types of mutations some of which you can
see on the slide here such as snips
somatic mutations insertions deletions
duplications even something more
complicated like copy number variations
but while those are the needs you may
have as a receipt a researcher you do
have options one of the options you see
is which technology should you use there
are many options starting with some
simple and more targeted approaches like
Sanger sequencing or PCR based based
methods and then there are more
complicated methods like next-generation
sequencing that is a more full genome
approach
so when choosing an option or technology
I think it's fair to say that you often
have to consider the specific experiment
or project you are working on for
example are you trying to discover new
mutations and perhaps looking for the
unknown or are you testing for a
specific mutation sample number and
sample amount can also weigh on what
sort of technology you want to choose
and lastly you may consider your
resources not just the amount of people
or technicians you have and their
skillsets available but also budget and
cost towards your genotyping effort for
example do you want them to spend their
time on genotyping methodology that
requires a robust knowledge of
bioinformatics analysis or would you
rather those resources be applied
elsewhere time could be of essence so
how quickly do you need the answer are
you willing to wait to send out for a
result or do you need it right away and
do you have those resources to do it
in-house and so after you weigh these
questions you can choose a technology
that fits your need high resolution
melting is a more targeted approach it
offers a broad selection of targets it
can detect what might be considered
tough or difficult targets it allows you
to test one sample at a time and still
be accurately able to call a genotype
this is not always the case in other
targeted methods like hydrolysis propia
PCR for example you can also distinguish
multiple snips or indulge in one gene
using HRM and the technology is cost
effective and fast in fact in most cases
it can be run within an hour and
sometimes what and it can be run on an
open platform the data analysis is
scalable and it can be very straight
forward due to the availability of
controls because of these advantages
that HRM offers cannon biomedical you
this technology to develop and launch
the novel genotyping assays these assays
have a very simple four-step protocol
the first step being DNA extraction
followed by sample preparation which
requires mixing the assay sample or
control with our high speed novel
genotyping master mix next is to run
those reactions on an instrument with
fluorescent detection that supports HRM
most real-time PCR instruments have HRM
capability I will be providing examples
of those towards the end of this
presentation finally the last step is to
analyze the data we offer no-boil
control sets that make analysis even
easier they allow you to compare your
sample melkor's to characterize
genotyping controls to easily call the
sample genotype in addition most
instruments support HRM analysis however
if you don't have the software packages
to analyze your data we do offer free
HRM software that is accessible online
HRM can be used to detect a variety of
different mutations our noble assay is
detect sniffs small insertions and
deletions and so what I mean by that are
those that are less than 6 base pairs
mitochondrial DNA targets which I will
discuss in a few slides and on mic
hydrolysis probe PCR HRM can detect much
larger deletion so those that are
greater than 200 base pairs and we even
offer some assays that the shot detect
over seven-and-a-half kilobases we also
offer copy number assays that use HRM as
I mentioned we offer genotyping controls
with our no real assays these are
characterized wild-type and homozygous
mutant controls the set can be combined
to create a heterozygous control as well
is used to identify sample genotypes by
comparing melt curves so let's get into
the application the first one being
mitochondrial DNA detection due to the
differences between mitochondrial DNA
and nuclear DNA detecting mitochondrial
DNA mutations is not as easy as
detecting nuclear DNA mutations while
there are two copies of nuclear DNA
there are greater than 1000 copies of
mitochondrial DNA mitochondrial DNA is
maternally inherited and has a much
higher mutation rate in fact 10 to 17
fold higher than nuclear DNA and more
than 250 pathogenic mitochondrial DNA
mutations have been identified
mitochondria are the energy factory of
our body several thousand mitochondria
are in nearly every cell in our body and
when mutations occur mitochondria can
fail to produce enough energy which can
cause disorder or mitochondrial disease
mitochondrial diseases can be present at
birth but can also occur at any age they
can affect almost any part of our body
including the cells of our brain nerves
muscles and kidneys one in 5,000
individuals has a mitochondrial disease
and each year about 1,000 to 4,000
children and the United States are born
with a mitochondrial disease known
examples of mitochondrial disease caused
by snip mutations include levers disease
maila syndrome and myoclonic epilepsy
and ragged red fiber disease symptoms of
these diseases can be found on this
slide but they're often neurological
problems such as dementia or muscle
weakness and pain so due to the
commonality in symptoms it's hard to
distinguish and diagnose based on
phenotype alone
mitochondria are derived from the ovum
and the mitochondrial DNA is therefore
maternally inherited a mother hearing
abnormal mitochondria will pass the
abnormal mitochondria to all of her
children but only her female offspring
will transmit the abnormal monk
mitochondria to future generations
affected males do not pass on the odd
Nordahl abnormal mitochondria however
both sexes can suffer from mitochondrial
disease detecting mitochondrial DNA
becomes even more complicated due to the
hetero cosmic nature of the mitochondria
genome so at first
usually all mitochondria of an
individual are identical this is known
as Homo plasma
however as individuals grow and the
cells begin to replicate mutations can
occur at random during the cellular
replication processes
this results in what's called
heteroplasmy which is the occurrence of
more than one type of mitochondrial DNA
when a cell has only a few mitochondria
with mutant mitochondria DNA the cell
can function normally
however if most of the mitochondria are
mutant then the cell function is most
likely severely altered and an altered
phenotype can be observed in the
presence of heteroplasmy the ratio of
wild-type to mutant mitochondrial DNA
can determine the onset of clinical
symptoms a minimum critical proportion
of mutated mitochondrial DNA is
necessary before biochemical defects and
tissue dysfunction become apparent canon
biomedical has developed HRM based
assays that target specific pathogenic
mutations in the mitochondrial genome
that are associated with some of the
more common mitochondrial diseases these
are the ones I spoke about earlier so
Murph male
and lho n and their associated diseases
can be found in the far right column on
the slide seen here common detection
methods for these targets like NGS or
sing or sequencing can be costly and
time-consuming our published research
has found that HRM mitochondrial DNA
mutex DNA detection is a scent is as
sensitive as these common methods and
the assays are able to detect mutations
and a hetero plasmic population and so
therefore these assays are a viable
alternative to other more costly
labor-intensive options this is one
example of the data from a male Asif a
the MELAS assay detects a mutation and
the MTL one gene this condition affects
many of the body systems particularly
the brain and the nervous system the
signs and symptoms of this disorder most
often appear in childhood following a
period of normal development although
they can begin at any age and most
affected individuals experience
stroke-like episodes beginning before
the age of 40 this essay here is an
unlabeled probe assay so there is a tall
peak on the far right that represents
the full sized amplicon and a smaller
peak to its left that represents the
probe amplicon hetero duplex where the
snip is present in the DNA these smaller
curves distinguish the three genotypes
here you can see that wild-type is in
black the homozygous mutant is in red
and the heterozygous genotype is in blue
this is an example of another
mitochondrial target that we offer this
assay is a small amplicon assay so it
generates one peak that distinguishes
the genotype
it's at axis snip in the end
and before Jean was which is associated
with lepers disease symptoms of this
disease include vision loss that often
occur in a person's teens or 20s I
mentioned how to oppose me before but
but detecting mitochondrial DNA becomes
even more complicated due to the hetero
posnick nature of the mitochondrial
genome it is very possible for only some
of the mitochondria to have a mutation
and you want to be able to detect that
mutation our research has found that the
Ozzie's we offer can detect
mitochondrial DNA mutations between 9
and 13 percent mutant DNA depending on a
mutation and therefore can detect
mutations even in a hetero cosmic
population we're only a portion of the
mitochondria contain that mutation the
second application i would like to
discuss is related to CRISPR more
specifically using HRM to screen CRISPR
derived edits I'm sure we can all agree
that CRISPR is a pretty hot topic as I'm
sure you aware CRISPR is a somewhat
newer simpler technology often used for
genome editing and it does create
genetic variants
however for background purposes CRISPR
does have two main components one being
guide RNA and the other being DNA
endonuclease Caston i'm the guide RNA
determines where insertions or deletions
may occur and directs cast 9 to bind to
that area cast 9 will then break the
double-stranded DNA and prepare to break
one of two ways those repair mechanisms
can be seen here the break can be
repaired by non-homologous end joining
or homology directed repair
homologous and joining can produce
insertions or deletions of variable
lengths and is a much more random repair
process whereas homology directed repair
has the ability to be more specific
it introduces precise point mutations or
insertions by way of a donor template
which you can see here on the right the
two mechanisms for CRISPR repair can
create challenges for gene editing and
when creating CRISPR clones this can be
an issue
therefore researchers need to screen the
clone population to see which ones
acquired the mutation or variation of
interest so due to the two repair
mechanisms not all clones will have a
specific mutation so the screening helps
determine those that successfully
inherited the mutation there are limited
downstream screening options for CRISPR
clones because CRISPR is introducing
genetic variation genotyping techniques
are often implemented into the screening
process current methods include jellies
cleavage kits however this can be
considered slow they lack sensitivity
and they are very hands-on
another option is self primer design or
nested PCR so this requires significant
expertise and can be time-consuming due
to the need of optimization and then you
can always use Sanger sequencing or NGS
however this can take time it often
requires the samples to be sent out and
it is more costly than the other two
options but what about HRM as we
discussed it is a useful way for
detecting genetic variants and as it
turns out scientist has accepted HRM as
a simple and effective way to screen for
CRISPR Drive mutations in fact a group
from Harvard recently published a
protocol in Cold Spring Harbor protocols
on how to use HRM for detecting
no mutations caused by CRISPR HRM can be
used for initial screening of early
cloned generations and it limits
sequencing at each step it is a cheaper
option and also reduces sample
preparation cost and it can detect rare
mutations and complex mutations that
arise from gene editing if you compare
HRM to other method it does compare
favorably especially in time cost skills
needed and sensitivity one group from
university of alabama recently published
a study that found that HRM was highly
efficient at detecting CRISPR derived
mutations in zebrafish the group used
HRM for rapid and efficient efficient
identification of nucleus derived
mutations to help advance cost
cost-effective hyper put methodologies
for mutation detection in this chart
they break down the results from there
HRM analysis on four different CRISPR
targeted genes and show that HRM was
able to detect all cells with a drive
mutation 100% of the time you may be
wondering what this workflow or protocol
looks like after identifying the target
and receiving the designed guide RNA you
can prepare a culture of the cells and
deliver the cast nine and the guide RNA
by one of two options so either through
a plasmid or as is and if you are trying
to repair the cells by inserting a
specific mutation you will want to
include a donor template to ensure
repair by HDR or homology directed
repair after the cells have been
transfected you will want to split and
dilute them for further enrichment
however at this time you will perform
your first screen to check if any cells
were edited and acquired the mutation if
using a char
you'll want to pool the cells extract
the DNA prepare the reactions and run on
a thermo cycler to determine the
genotype next is to continue with
enrichment and successfully identify
self with the wanted mutation by HRM
analysis cells that are determined to be
wild-type can be removed from the study
you will want to only move forward with
heterozygous and homozygous cells
finally after the cell line has been
edited you can send the final edit
itself to sequencing to verify to edit
using this method decreases upfront
costs for screening early enrichment of
the CRISPR drive clones and limits the
amount of sequencing needed to screen
your CRISPR clones the Nova genotyping
assays use HRM to detect snips and in
dolls for clinically relevant variants
here you can see how the data analysis
from these assays easily made clear what
variation has been created this is an
advantage that might not be as clear
using other methods of variant detection
in this clean case the Black Milk curve
is once again homozygous wild-type
the red milk curve is homozygous mutant
and the blue milk curve is header as
heterozygous the next example today that
I want to focus on is our
pharmacogenetic offerings
pharmacogenetics is the study of the
relationship between genetic variations
and how our body responds to medications
a genetic test can give important
information about how a person's genetic
variations may change that person's
response to a drug and can suggest ways
to change drug dose or choice to improve
medical treatment for that person right
now many drugs are prescribed as though
they work the same in all people
sometimes the dose of the drug is
adjusted depending on an age
sighs or gender of the patient however
because of genetic variation not all
people will respond to the same way to
the same drug treatment pharmacogenetic
testing gives insight into how an
individual patient may respond to a drug
pharmgkb is a website that has over six
hundred and twenty-one related drugs
related to pharmacogenetics and offers
information on 476 drug labels the drugs
are labeled based on their testing
recommendation seen on this slide here
so anything from testing required where
the label states testing should be
conducted using before using the drug to
inform it as PGX where the label
mentions a gene or potentially a protein
that is involved in the metabolism or
pharmacodynamics of the drug canon
biomedical offers over ninety genetic
targets specific to pharmacogenetic
research on this slide there are a few
examples of those you can see the
targets the variant type and the
specific drug interaction today I want
to focus on these three in particular
252 c9 targets and one vko rc1 target
all of these targets interact with the
drug warfarin for some background
warfarin is one of the most widely
prescribed anticoagulant drugs worldwide
it acts as an inhibitor to the zk o RC
one receptor 40% of dose variants could
be explained by looking at genetic
polymorphisms in the vko rc1 and the SIP
2c9 genes and lower doses are suggested
for individuals with these types of
mutations in this section I want to
discuss a particular study that was
recently published earlier this year
from University of Florida in a study
the lab compared three
genotyping solutions for these three
specific snips associated with warfarin
metabolism the researchers compared our
novel genotyping assays Pacman's
hydrolysis probe assays and luciferase
based pyrosequencing by cryogen they
looked at both blood and saliva samples
and tested these three mutations a
mutation in the zk o r c1 can cause
warfarin resistance a mutation and the
69 star 2 will reduce metabolism by 30%
and a mutation in the star 369 reduces
metabolism by 90% this slide shows the
genotyping data for the blood samples
the overall concordance was greater than
99% there was one sample that was
determined to be homozygous wild-type
for the z KO rc1 gene by both the noble
assay and the pyrosequencing that
nothing however that same sample was
actually undetermined by tack man this
slide shows the HRM melt curves for the
three targets with blood samples you can
see that the variants are easily
distinguishable again the wild-type is
shown in black the homozygous mutant is
in red and the heterozygous samples are
in blue for all three snips
this slide shows the concordance in the
saliva samples again tack man failed to
determine one of the samples this time
however it was a heterozygous sip to see
nine star three sample the overall
concordance in saliva was 100% with
three methodologies this slide looks
similar to the blood sample so as you
can see DNA extracted from blood and
saliva will give similar results here
you can see that the three genotypes are
easily distinguishable
overall the researchers found that HRM
analysis is a fast and cost-effective
reliable method to detect a wide range
of mutations and the comparison proves
that noble assays are reliable compared
to the two common options the last
application I would like to discuss is
our neuroscience targets specifically
the gene a PO
and its relation to Alzheimer's disease
Kanon biomedical offers over 80 targets
specific to neuroscience and associated
neurological diseases on this slide you
can see handful of the targets we offer
and the specific diseases they associate
with including our apoE targets related
to Alzheimer's disease for those of you
that don't know a poly is a gene that
encodes for April lipoprotein II which
is responsible for maintaining
cholesterol levels because of this apoE
is often associated with things like
heart disease hypertension type 2
diabetes but what it is most associated
with as Alzheimer's disease we offer two
specific assays that help distinguish
the apoE alleles and there are three
common a pony alleles a poly two three
and four
a pony three is the most common allele
and is found in more than half the
population and it's considered to be the
wild-type the two assays we offer detect
snips in the apoE gene that cause an
amino acid change based on the variation
or mutation for example if you look at
the chart if a sample was wild-type for
both assays that we offer that sample
could be categorized as a Poe East three
if the sample was mutant for both it
could be categorized as a Poe if for
for some more background everyone has
two copies of a gene and the combination
determines you're a poet genotype the e2
allele is the rarest form of a PO
with an allele frequency of
approximately 8% in the general
population and caring even one copy
appears to reduce the risk of developing
Alzheimer's by up to 40% the apoe4
allele is present in approximately 10 to
15% of the general population but 40% of
people with Alzheimer's disease this
allele increases the risk for
Alzheimer's and lowers the age of onset
and having one copy of efore so for
example an e3 e4 genotype can increase
your risk by two to three times while
having two copies can increase your risk
by 12 on this slide you can see data
derived from blood samples that were
tested with one of our ape ofE you can
see that all three genotypes wild-type
homozygous and heterozygous are easily
distinguishable based on their milk
curve we understand that it's not always
easy to obtain positive controls for
unique mutations and because of this
Canon biomedical has developed
characterized genotyping controls for
genotyping assays including this apoE
assay on the right hand side of the
slide you can now see that by art by
using our Neuville controls you can
compare the sample curve data which is
seen in green and red to the known Curt
control curve data seen in blue before I
conclude I would like to quickly show
you how you can find your target of
interest today
this slide here based on the products
that are offered in the Nobel portfolio
that I've discussed I want to quickly
mention that if you have your own
primers and probes
you can pair them with our noble
genotyping master MINIX and all ago
dilution buffer to implement the fast
high speed scary I spoke about today the
products are all shipped at ambient
conditions and aziz and master mix can
be stored at four degrees celsius the
controls should be stored at minus
twenty each assay offers 166 reactions
for 10 micro litre reactions in the
beginning of the presentation I showed
you a protocol that requires HRM capable
thermocycler noble chemistry can be run
on any HRM capable thermal cycler
however we have tested and validated
market leading instruments found on this
slide here so you can see common
instruments maybe even those found in
your own lab such as bio-rad CF x 96 and
384 brushes light cyclers thermo
Fisher's quant studios and cryogens
rotor gene q platform I have to
apologize I see the slides a little
blurry and you may not be able to make
out everything but if you are interested
in seeing the type of targets we offer
outside of the ones discussed in the
presentation today or if you want to
learn more about the targets I discussed
you can visit our website at wkyt.com
here you can search for an assay by one
of two methods so you can search by
research topic which is seen on the left
so for example you could choose
neuroscience or pharmacogenetics and
then the other way you can search is by
our assay database which is seen here on
the right where you can type in a
specific gene target such as a PO
or even search by drug interaction like
warfarin or tamoxifen for example once
you choose a target to view you can find
the catalog number for the assay and the
catalog number for the associated
control at the top
the page which you can see here in the
red box along with other specific
information about the target including
example data curves if you scroll down
the page I mentioned this earlier but we
also offer free online software for HRM
analysis it is an intuitive easy-to-use
tool that allows you to visualize four
different graphs from your HRM data
including melt curves normalized curves
derivative curves and different spots in
addition the tool allows you to auto
cluster your data based off of curve
likeness if you want to learn more you
can visit our virtual booth or you can
see a demo of the software online to
access the software you can visit the
website here and with his software
cannon - biomechanical comm and you can
register to use the software has a help
page the link is highlighted here in red
the help page is essentially a user
guide and can help navigate the software
and even offer it sample files to play
with and test before I get to questions
I would like to summarize by saying that
I hope you can now see how HRM and Noble
can help detect your toughest target HRM
detects a variety of targets including
snips in Dells rare alleles and
mitochondrial DNA and Noble delivers a
bench tested simple protocol with rapid
results that is cost effective
it offers genotyping control so you are
not limited to sample number and you can
test as little as one sample at a time I
urge you to reach out today to see how
Neuville can detect can help detect your
tough target thank you so much for
attending this session we do have a
virtual booth at this event and if you
are looking for literature or an
interested in learning
or please visit are there any questions
before I close today Thank You Dana for
that informative presentation we
appreciate it and we now want to start
with our live audience portion of QA for
this webinar if you have any questions
audience members you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of your
presentation window type that question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for so
we do have some questions coming in
already Dana our first question is is
this offered as a service
so that's a great question that we often
receive these assays are not offered as
as a service through can a file medical
they are sold as reagents to run in your
own lab great thank you our next
question from our audience is can you
multiplex using these products
another good question so these assays
use one die and so they are not
multiplex capable we do offer some
assays that are multi target which means
they're able to discriminate between
more than one snip or endo within the
same gene but again all of our assays
are single Plex thank you and Dana why
would wouldn't want to use this
technology versus something like
hydrolysis probe PCR or maybe TaqMan
okay so hydrolysis probe PCR which is
also another targeted approach often
requires or actually does require a
minimum of samples to form clusters and
call the appropriate genotype our
technology doesn't require a minimum a
minimum number of samples so you don't
have to rely on dodging and then we also
provide controls to help make that
analysis even easier in addition we have
a number of unique targets like our
mitochondrial DNA targets that I talked
about but even some of our multi target
discrimination targets and our large
deletion assays that do not have
hydrolysis probe solutions available for
similar targets great thank you and
thank you to our audience members we
have some great questions coming in our
next question is two parts what is the
best sensitivity of HRM and can I use
HRM to detect somatic mutations
yeah that's a great question so HRM is
highly sensitive and so in most studies
sensitivity can be anywhere from 98 to
100 percent so top sensitivity is around
100 percent that's often in one of those
unlabeled probe assays which I showed an
example of and then you can use HRM to
detect somatic mutations there are many
papers out there that use HRM to detect
somatic mutations however all the assays
that we offer in our novel library ICANN
and biomedical are for inherited target
thank you for that we have one more
question from our audience what if you
don't have my target of interest right
so we offer over 350 different targets
but if we don't have your target of
interest
we are currently expanding our portfolio
in fact many of the assays that we
develop come from researchers in the
field looking for a simple and effective
method to genotype their samples so
depending on your target of interest we
could potentially customize a particular
assay we would ask you to reach out and
we can have that discussion offline and
then in addition I mentioned this
towards the end of the presentation but
we do offer our noble chemistry and this
sort of create your own assay format so
what you would do is you would buy the
novel genotyping master mix and the
dilution buffer and then you could mix
them with your own primers for the
target that you're trying to genotype I
hope that answers your question it does
thank you so much Tina and I want to
thank audience members for their
questions and please know that any
questions further coming in after the
presentation Dina is happy to answer by
email Dina did you have any closing
remarks you'd like to share with our
audience today
I just wanted to thank everyone for
attending the presentation I also wanted
to mention that you can connect with us
on LinkedIn and Facebook we are can and
biomedical we post all of our new
product announcements even our press
releases there so if you want to keep up
on the latest news of Canon biomedical
we urge you to check us on those
channels and connect with us Thank You
Deena and thank you again for your
presentation I also would like to thank
canon biomechanical and lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before I go I want to let
everyone in the audience know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through March of 2017
I'm sorry 2018 you will receive an email
from lab roots letting you know when the
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who missed may and miss
today's live event that's all for now
and thanks for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye bye everyone